انضم لينا من عمان اللواء فايز دويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي الوقت دويري
ما الذي ترصده من تطور في الجبهات لا سيما
في يتعلق بالهجوم الاوكراني على مواقع
القوات الروسيه
يعني هذه الفتره هناك هدوء
واضح جدا فيما يتعلق بالعمليات الميدانيه
التعرضيه هناك مجموعه من العوامل ادت الى
انخفاض وتيره هذه العمليات في الجانب
الاوكراني عمليه نقل وتهيئه القوات
والحديث عن احتماليه سنه هجوم الربيع الذي
يتطلب اعاده بناء القوه وتموضع هذه القوه
بالنسبه للجانب الروسي
اخفاقاته في محاوله السيطره على فخمه
والانتفاع عنها همم الى مسافه ماء نقص
المخزونات من الصواريخ وبالتالي بدات توجه
باستخدام الطائرات المسيرات اكثر مما كان
يعتمد سابقا على الصواريخ اذا دعني اقول
نحن لم تدخل هذه القوات في مصطلح حرب
الاستنزاف بمعناه التقليدي ولكنها اقرب ما
تكون الى حرب استنزاف لعدم وجود عمليات
عسكريه تعرضيه تحقق نتائج تفضي الى تطوير
الهجمات في المدى القريب في هذه الاثناء
يبرز همم يعني دعوات لوقفه الاقمار من
جانب واحد كما طالب الرئيس اردوغان ودعوات
لهدنه اليوم واحد كما طالبت الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه ماذا تفهم من هذا المشهد ومن
هذه الدعوات في هذا التوقيت اللواء دويري
يعني هي محاولات تركيه همم قديمه جديده
تحاول ان تجد شيء ارضيه صلبه للاتفاق لكن
الحديث الان كان مع الرئيس الروسي هل يقصد
بالجانب الواحد ان تعلن روسيا وقفه اطلاق
النار من جانبها ام كان يطلب الجانب
الاخراني الجانب الاوكراني رفض فقط ورفض
مجرد هدنه للاحتفالات اذا هو من باب اولى
ان يرفض بالمطلق وقف العمليات الكليه ما
دام الواقع الميداني الحالي يعني السيطره
على اجزاء كبيره جدا من اربعه اقاليم هل
الجانب الروسي مستعد الجانب الروسي غير
اعتقد غير مستعد لوقف اطلاق النار لماذا
لان القرار السياسي لا يزال يتحدث عن
الاخذ بالواقع الميداني ليس الانس يعني
يرفض كليا يطالب في تطبيق الشروط الروسيه
بدءا من همم تجريد الجيش الاوكراني من
سلاحه تخفيض عدده الى 50,000 مقاتل عدم
الانضمام الى احلام القضاء على النازيه
والاخذ بالواقع الميداني اذا دعني اقول
الفجوه كبيره جدا وكان كلا الطرفين يسيران
في خطوط متوازي يصعب ان تلتقي في ظل هذا
الواقع الميداني الضباب والرمادي شكرا لك
فايزه دويره الخبير العسكري واستجي في
عمان